una elección que enfrentó a dos pesos
pesados de la política mohammed razón
mano derecha del presidente saliente de
níger y mamá neus mané quien se
convirtió en el primer líder
democráticamente electo del país en 1993
antes de ser derrocado en un golpe de
estado tres años después este domingo
los votantes de la capital nigerina
esperaban que el resultado de la
votación fuera ante todo uno la paz
yo he elegido a quien quiero que dirija
mi país
todo lo que quiero es que estas
elecciones sean pacíficas tranquilas y
completamente transparentes y de la
transición total de paz de diegote antal
no puedo decirles por quien vote pero
aún así es un nigerino el que será
votado y que cuidara del pueblo la cual
se iniciaría nunca deseo la paz en níger
después de esta votación la iniciara
aprecio voto sin embargo níger se
encuentra en estado de emergencia desde
2017 mientras lucha contra las
insurgencias yihadistas que se han
extendido desde malí
nigeria inestabilidad que hizo eco en
esta jornada con 7 trabajadores
electorales muertos en el occidente del
país luego de que su vehículo chocara
contra una mina a principios de enero
100 ciudadanos murieron tras un ataque a
dos aldeas cercanas a la frontera de
níger con malí miles de soldados fueron
desplegados en todo el país para la
votación de este 21 de febrero que
marcará el inicio de un traspaso
pacífico entre presidentes electos por
primera vez desde la independencia de
níger de francia en 1960 sólo 7,4
millones de los 22 millones de
habitantes del país eran elegibles para
votar se esperan resultados no más de 72
horas después del cierre de las urnas
[Música]